lionel petitpas président de
l'association victimes du coc vie 19
estime justement que cet hommage
pourrait être une étape pour faciliter
le deuil des familles moi j'ai toujours
dit que l'hommage ne ferait pas le deuil
bien sûr que le deuil est toujours
difficile à faire même au bout d'un an
vu les circonstances dans lesquelles nos
proches sont partis mais mais c'est une
étape qui va nous permettre de faire le
deuil
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
hormis que le président de la république
prend la parole c'est aussi le père de
la nation et dans ce cadre là c'est la
nation qui rend un hommage aux personnes
décédées de la copie 19 et c'est
également pour le rendre ce respect
cette dignité et cette reconnaissance
dont ils ont tant manqué dans les phases
que l'on a connu des premières vagues
notamment il ya toujours de la tristesse
même au bout d'un an
très honnêtement mon deuil est toujours
pas fait je n'arrive pas à le faire si
on m'a volé un moment vous savez quand
on m'a annoncé le décès demande épouse à
6h18 le système a appris ma femme elle
ne m'a plus appartenu je n'ai plus eu
mon mot à dire
le système m'a pris ma femme sans que je
puisse faire quoi que ce soit